the left launches its war on children
the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals
declares that a high school football
coach can't kneel at the 50-yard line
and pray plus we do the mailbag I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show so
you've made it gang we're here it's a
Friday and I want to talk to you about
something that's been disturbing me for
a long time and no I'm not talking about
my loss of hair I'm talking about the
fact that the left is is moving in
significant fashion to impact how we
raise our kids and it really is
upsetting and a problem and I want to
talk about all of that plus we'll talk
about is President Trump actually
sinking the possibility of the
Republicans retaining the house in 2018
and the Senate in 2018 which is nearly
impossible we'll get to all that plus
the mailbag so if you're gonna buy a
subscription today's the day to do it
because that means you get to be part of
the mailbag we'll do live questions
later
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Skillshare so are you a
professional looking to broaden your
skill set are you looking to do your job
better do you just want to add some
skills to your resume you should be
doing all of these things if you wish to
have upper mobility in terms of income
and the fact is that we live in a job
market where if you're not constantly
increasing your skill set then you are
less and less competitive in the job
market especially with new people
graduating in and moving into the job
market every single year so you really
ought to be engaging with the folks over
at Skillshare it's an online learning
community with over 15,000 classes in
design business and more you can learn
everything from logo design to social
media marketing to street photography
unlimited access to all of this for a
low monthly price and you never have to
pay per class even buy it for a low
monthly price right now I have been
looking specifically at some of their
firm for fun I do some their
illustration and watercolor classes
seriously yes and I can draw now yeah
that's because of skill sure so go to
skills show right now right now my
listeners are getting a month of
unlimited access absolutely free when
you go to skill shared comm slash
Shapiro to redeem your free month at
skill shared comm slash of hero again
adds that resume because your incoming
going up unless your skill set increases
that's what skill share is therefore
skill share calm Shapiro to redeem your
free month make sure you use that slash
capiro also so that they know that we
sent you ok so there's
yesterday that really got under my skin
is from my senator here in the state of
California she was the Attorney General
here
she's a garbage senator she was a
garbage Attorney General and she's
probably gonna be a garbage presidential
candidate she's obviously looking toward
running it in 2020 and there's always
been this very weird relationship
between the left and kids when it comes
to politics Hillary Clinton made her
bones on this book it takes a village
all about how it really took all of us
to define how we were going to raise
particular children they weren't your
children they were the villages children
and then you see people on the Left who
don't care about unborn children
suggesting that they're the only ones
who care about children so Kamala Harris
tweets this out yesterday she tweeted
out children are our nation's future we
must listen to them about what they care
about and give them a voice in our
government so again weird that she
doesn't care about them up until the
point where they're born yeah up until
that point you can kill them at will and
in fact if you stand in the way of
somebody killing them well that means
you're a bad person but also this notion
that children are the nation's future
and so we have to listen to them about
what they care about and give them a
voice in our government no so one of the
big problems in Western civilization has
been this this weird notion that's
really cropped up since Rousseau in the
early in the early 19th century that
children are worth listening to
okay children are worth taking seriously
the questions are worth answering I
treat my three-year-old with great
seriousness when she asked me a question
I tried to give her the most actual
answer that I can provide but if she
were to give me world advice I would say
you're three sit down and eat your
crackers okay it's ridiculous for anyone
to suggest that children are what should
be defining voice in government is the
first sentence is that children our
nation's future that's true they are not
our present okay they are not our
nation's present it is your job as an
adult to help civilize children have you
ever met a child I wonder if people on
the Left have met a child like really
met a child children are the worst
people on earth okay they're wonderful
and they are also the worst people on
earth
they have no prefrontal cortex
development they don't have the capacity
for inhibition that means that your
child does stuff what if an adult did it
you would immediately have them carted
off to jail
I got a routine basis children smack
each other okay if you're an adult you
just walked up to people and smack them
for no
they would go to jail for that right
children routinely take other people's
property and break it children scream at
you okay children are little nut jobs
and they're they're awesome they're
wonderful but that's also because you
know they're going to develop beyond
that if they're 20 and still acting like
they're three that means they're garbage
human being the whole point of
civilization is to civilize children
your job as a parent is to civilize
children and to make them better people
because children are not instinctively
good Rousseau wrote this jean-jacques
Rousseau wrote this book called Emile
which was it was a novel about a child
who's basically left free in the state
of nature
Rousseau's whole theory is that in a
state of nature man is inherently good
and then the state puts us all in Chains
right man is free and everywhere he is
in Chains
this is Russo's theory and so what he
says in a meal is basically if you just
let a child laundry around in nature and
that child would become a noble savage
that child would be a beautiful
wonderful person capable of navigating
the vicissitudes of life absolute
nonsense number one if you live a
three-year-old alone nature that'll be
dead in two days number two if you leave
a ten-year-old alone in nature the kid
will turn into something from more to
the fly is killing animals and other
children the idea that people are born
civilized is just stupid that's the
whole point of civilization
it's what religion is based on religion
is based on the notion that you as an
adult
have to civilize it and raise your
children and you have to acclimate them
to acting morally it's not something
that is inborn
it's not something that is inbred okay
the fact is that there's a concept in in
Jewish law it's called Teno janeshia
okay it means literally a baby that was
found so there are certain basic rules
in Judaism that you're not supposed to
violate and even if you're not Jewish
you're not supposed to violate these
rules and these are simple ones like
don't murder people don't commit
idolatry right these are certain basic
rules for everyone if you want to get
into heaven according to Judaism you
don't have to be Jewish but you do have
to fulfill what they call the seven
mitzvahs of Nowak it's a full of seven
commandments of Noah right because Noah
existed before the Torah had been given
these are Commandments that you're
supposed to be able to suss out from the
surrounding universe but if you don't
actually do a lot of the let's say
there's a kid who's born Jewish where I
born to a Jewish family and left in the
middle of nowhere and doesn't fulfill
any of the 613 mitzvot than any of the
613 commandments that's where this
concept of T notion ish part comes in we
don't blame that person because that kid
was basically like a kid
was found in the woods raised Mowgli so
you don't expect Mowgli to be civilized
and in fact there was the remember a few
years ago there's this story about a
little girl who was basically left alone
for years and years and years they found
her when she was like twelve years old
and she acted like an animal what else
would you expect her to do she was she
was growing up in a place that was
basically surrounded by animals how you
raise your children matters this idea
that children are going to that they
have some sort of god-given innocence
and wisdom that is that is something
that we should listen to know they have
a god-given wonder about the world that
is amazing to behold and lovely and it
reminds you how beautiful life is
because when you view the world through
a child's eyes it reminds you that
things around you are really cool and
really interesting but kids moral
notions are usually really really stupid
because kids are little immoral cretins
okay they only get smart later again
their brains are not developed to the
point where they can actually have smart
moral thoughts okay this is why even
teenagers are not really developed to
the point where they have smart moral
thoughts the the reason the teenagers
act like idiots all the time is because
their amygdala which is their motion
sensor in their brain is overdeveloped
and their prefrontal cortex which is the
inhibition sensor is underdeveloped so
that's why that's why teenagers do
stupid stuff so when she says we have to
give children a voice in our government
what you want three-year-olds to vote
but what what really underlies this
perception what really underlies this
perception the left doesn't really
believe that children are to be making
their own decisions the left believes
that they ought to be making decisions
for your children and the left doesn't
believe that children are to be making
decisions for society they believe that
they ought to be making decisions for
your children and the only reason that
your children are growing up in the way
they are is because of you you are the
problem if they were allowed to raise
your children and everything would be
fine now they can't just say that if
you're if you're on the hard left you
can't just say this you can't just say
listen I think I'm gonna do a better job
raising your kid than you will you can't
say that because number one it's not
true and number two it makes you a
jackass have you come to me and you say
I'm gonna raise your kid better than you
well then I would say to you you can go
take a hike son if you try to take my
kid from me I'd meet at the front door
with a shotgun so what is the left you
instead what instead they do is they say
children are beautiful innocent little
creatures but fully capable of making
their own decisions and if you inhibit
the decision-making process of a
three-year-old then you are the villain
we must step in to protect the
independence of the three-year-old right
we're basically the American government
fighting the British we're stepping in
to protect the citizen the citizen is
the three-year-old we have to protect
that three-year-old from you the
oppressive evil parent who's putting
your notions about God and heaven and
hell on kids how dare you do all of
these things it's because of you their
kid is growing up with all of these
problems if your kid were just allowed
to make their own decisions it's just
like a meal and everything would be fine
and it's our job to step in and make
sure the kids can make their own
decisions that's how you end up with
idiocy 'he's like this story from
Rockland Academy schools which is a
Sacramento area charter school this is a
pobla of Daily wire reporting a
kindergarten teacher at Rockland Academy
schools a Sacramento area charter school
recently held a transition ceremony to
celebrate what she believed was the
transgenderism of a five-year-old boy in
her class who fancies himself a girl and
she did it without obtaining consent
from or even notifying parents facing
legal trouble from parents rightly
outraged over having their children
exposed to transgenderism without their
knowledge Rockland Academy schools
maintains they had no obligation to
inform the parents since California laws
require consent only in matters of sex
education so let me get this straight
it's not sex education when you decide
to tell a five-year-old boy that it can
be a five-year-old girl the lesson they
say had to do with gender identity which
the school claims falls under tolerance
and diversity curricula the students who
took part in the ceremony were
reportedly left shaken and disturbed yes
yes somebody if somebody did this to my
kid if somebody lives seriously if
somebody did this to my kid they would
be in physical danger from me like that
if you did this to my kid if you decided
to take my parenting power away from my
child from me and and pretend that you
are going to raise my child as the
opposite sex and thereby stamp their
their psyche with gender confusion and
put the Aprilia tour of societal
approval on that gender confusion you're
doing something truly evil hey Jonathan
Keller is a representative for
California family group who's a group
involved in counseling some of the kids
said parents only learned of the
ceremony from their kids which began
with a lesson on transgenderism that
involved two books I am jazz and the red
cran that were both about the subject
I am jazz of course is about that that
kid who's on reality TV who quote from
the time she
two years old jazz knew that she had a
girl's brain in a boy's body again this
is biologically incorrect and it's
asinine okay there is no such thing as a
girl's brain in a boy's body again there
because and that's true because you
don't actually have evidence of what a
girl's brain looks like it's so funny
the feminists who say there is no
difference between a girl's brain and a
boys brain suddenly they go completely
silent when you say it's a girl's brain
in a boy's body you have to show me the
actual parts of the brain that operate
more like the girls than a boys and then
we can decide whether or not this is
true it's possible that there are people
who have brain development that is more
similar to a girl than a boy those would
presumably be genetically intersex
people but the idea that any boy is
capable of having a girl's brain his
body if he thinks it's oh not real but
again this is the left saying that
parents can't have a say in their own
child's future because we're defending
the children don't you understand we're
defending their innocence do you
understand that by suggesting that a
child makes their own decision you are
ripping away their innocent their
innocence the hallmark of adulthood is
the capacity to make your own decision
the hallmark of childhood is to be free
not to make your own decisions on
matters of weighty import that's what
parents are for it's your job to have
fun it's your parents job to take care
of you and it's your job to learn and
that's what being a child is all about
but the left has reverses polarity now
adults never have to take responsibility
for their decisions but children are to
be left alone to make their own
decisions and if you intervene as a
parent you're the bad guy and before I
go any further here and there's another
story I want to talk about that has some
relevance here first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at USC CA so I
want to tell you the story of a guy
named Buddy but he's an army vet who
spends his life defending his country
and his fellow man but when buddy needed
help the screwed up legal system turned
on him and threw him in jail for
defending his family when his daughters
angry ex-boyfriend showed up on buddy's
doorstep with a gang of thugs he
protected his family but when the cops
showed up they arrested him that's when
buddy called us CCA and because he knew
that his membership gave him exclusive
access to a network of pro-second
amendment attorneys upfront funding for
bail and legal fees and the peace of
mind that someone was on his side he was
okay the u.s. CCA got buddy back to his
daughter back to his wife and his life
and they can do the exact same thing for
you make sure that you are covered
defend my family now.com defend my
family now calm in case you ever have to
fire a gun I promise you the police are
going to do something about it and you
need to be protected for that go to
defend my family now come today
more true stories and to discover how
you can win a brand new gun they also
give away guns to some people who
register so you have a chance to win one
if you go to defend my family now calm
again let's defend my family now calm
education/training you have a chance to
win a firearm and protection in case you
actually have to fire one in a
self-defense situation defend my family
now calm go and check it out USC CA does
wonderful work and you should go give
them a look okay so in this ceremony
getting back to the ceremony in this
kindergarten class LifeSite News
described it this way after the teacher
introduced the five year old students of
the class as a boy he then went into the
bathroom and emerged too dressed as a
girl the teacher then reintroduced her
to the children explaining that she was
now a girl who know how to girls name
and it should be called that from now on
according to Keller who's this guy from
the family group he said kids were left
really deeply emotionally bothered and
traumatized there were several of the
little girls that went to their parents
and were crying saying mommy or daddy am
I going to turn into a boy this is evil
it's evil okay teachers who are teaching
entire classrooms of small children that
they can magically transform into
members of the opposite sex okay it's so
funny these people will say that if you
teach people about religion but that's
teaching the myth that if you teach them
about Santa Claus or the Easter Bunny
that that's myth okay this is
significantly more mythical because it
runs absolutely counter to biology and
the idea that kids are not malleable
when it comes to sexual orientation
they're not malleable when it comes to
gender identity there's no science that
demonstrates that at all none okay there
there may be genetic predispositions for
transgenderism there may be there may be
genetic predispositions on sexual
orientation but to suggest that
environment plays no part is to ignore
every single piece of available data
ever like all of it not some of it all
of it and yet this is what they say
because there's an agenda right the
agenda is to make it clear to children
that gender identity is fluid this is
one of the things left wants to do is
tear down the basic building blocks of
Western civilization in order to build
something anew if we're all widgets if
we're all just claymation figures and
they're a little in their little parable
of life then they get to more of us
however we want they get to mold us and
morph us however they want and that
means taking over our children and using
them against us and using them against
our standards of right and wrong so the
left which will say that they have the
power to go in until your five-year-old
child that he may be a girl right this
is the same left it says that if a
teacher preys on the 50-yard line that
that teacher ought to be fired there's
the case out of the Ninth Circuit Court
of Appeals today it's an amazing case ok
Bremerton School District is a is a
school district in Washington State and
the assistant football coach and one of
their high schools a guy named Joseph
Kennedy prayed at the 50-yard line after
football games and before them as well
students frequently joined him he would
also give them religiously oriented
motivational speeches the school
district tried to punish him for doing
this he settled for praying alone after
games but then he began praying at the
50-yard line before everyone gone home
so instead of waiting til everyone leave
left and then praying at the 50-yard
line
he would go over right after the game
game is over he goes over he prays at
the 50-yard line and surprise surprise
a lot of the kids started joining him
and people started coming down out of
the stands to join him praying on the
50-yard line end of the world
how dare he public school teacher
praying by himself on the 50-yard line
people joining him voluntarily must be
fired so the school district fired him
they suspended him and then they allowed
his contract to expire so Kennedy suit
he suggested religious discrimination
under the First Amendment the 9th
Circuit Court of Appeals found the
School District had every right to
dismiss Kennedy so there were two legal
questions here the first legal question
was was he a public employee second was
as a public employee did he violate his
job description as a public employee by
doing this so there are two separate
legal questions the court said when
Kennedy kneeled and prayed on the
50-yard line immediately after games
well in view of students and parents he
spoke as a public employee not as a
private citizen and his speech therefore
was constitutionally unprotected the
case they make in favor of this idea is
one he's still wearing all of his high
school gear second if you were just a
citizen you couldn't walk out to the
middle of the 50-yard line right you
have to be a member of the high school
staff in order to do this so I think
that this is actually legally arguable
is he doing this as a private citizen or
is he doing this on school grounds on
school time and therefore he's doing it
as a public employee it's a little bit
it's a little bit more confusing than
that because the fact is that if you're
at school like fine we're a public
school teacher and then I decided to
dive in medical which is the second
Jewish prayer of the day and I went in a
broom closet somewhere and prayed prayed
minica that doesn't mean that I would
necessarily be acting as a public school
employee clearly I'm a 10
two separate separate myself the court
found he was acting however in his
auspices as a public school in employee
but that isn't really the worst part the
worst part is that the court then said
what he did violated his job description
okay praying at the 50-yard line doing a
voluntary prayer that people decide to
join violates his job description now
let me explain what his job description
was okay Kennedy's job included becoming
quote a coach mentor and role model for
the student athletes it included in
explicit job requirements to attempt to
create both good athletes and good human
beings is directly in his job
description
Kennedy's postgame prayers originally
lasted a grand total of 30 seconds there
were a brief quiet prayer of
thanksgiving for player safety
sportsmanship and spirited competition
over time they morphed into motivational
speeches given to students of both teams
even people on the other team would come
over because they enjoyed what he was
saying about sportsmanship in the games
students voluntarily wanted to hear him
the district suggested these activities
violated school board policy that said
that quote staff shall neither encourage
nor discourage a student from engaging
in non-disruptive
oral or silent prayer or any other form
of devotional activity ok this didn't
violate that the guy literally went out
to the 50-yard line note down and prayed
that's it
he didn't say people have to show up he
didn't force anybody he didn't tell
people that if they showed up and they
didn't show up then they'd be kicked off
the team were suspended the school board
openly acknowledged that Kennedy didn't
force anyone to pray with him but the
school board insisted that Kennedy not
allows students to pray with him at all
they should forcibly turn them away if
he goes to the 50-yard line and kneels
down and he starts to pray and a bunch
of students crowd around him that this
is some sort of evil that he's violated
his public school duties and he should
tell them forcibly get out of here
you're not allowed to be here they said
any activity had to be quote physically
separate from any student activity and
students may not be allowed to join such
an activity so what actually started all
of this would actually started all this
is of course he did this 50-yard prayer
thing and the Satanists being good
Satanists devotees of Satan suggested
they wanted their own right to pray on
the field because obviously there's no
difference between Satan is praying on
the field and people of judeo-christian
values praying on the field not all
religions are created equal in quality
if you're gonna bring up a child in the
Church of Satan
I don't think that child ends up exactly
the same as if you bring the average
child is if you bring up a child in the
in the judeo-christian value system if
it were then Satanism would have created
the greatest civilization in the history
of mankind it didn't okay the so the
district responded by telling Kennedy he
had to pray only when the stadium was
empty he disobeyed and he started
praying right after the game is because
he said listen it doesn't make any sense
for me to pray an hour after the game on
the 50-yard line the game just ended I
want to thank God for a good game and
for everyone staying safe now it's a
good time to do it so the court found in
favor of the district so as I say first
they found that he was a public employee
they said the speech at issue is
directly at least in part to the
students and the surrounding spectators
it is not solely speech directed to God
so this is really dicey territory the
court is getting into right now they're
saying that his prayer was directed as a
public school employee at others hey I
wear a yarmulke I wear it around it's a
public sign of my faith millions and
millions and millions of Americans
including many people on the Left wear
crosses around their neck that is a
public proclamation of faith is that
them privately saying I believe in Jesus
who are the cross or I believe in the
Jewish God if you view our yarmulke or
is that me preaching to you do you feel
preached to every time I wear my
yarmulke because if you do I would
suggest that maybe you need to get a
life if you feel preached to because you
don't like what I wear on my head and
this is because you are a loser okay and
if you feel preached to because a high
school coach by himself goes to the
50-yard line and prays then you are a
doofus and a loser and you need to get a
life but obviously that's not the
priority here the court said by kneeling
and praying on the 50-yard line
immediately after games Kennedy was
fulfilling his professional
responsibility to communicate
demonstrative ly to students and
spectators yet he took advantage of his
position to press his particular views
upon the impressionable and captive
minds before him so they're saying okay
so his viewpoint means something because
he was acting as an employee that brings
us to the second question and the second
question is did that violate his job
which is to create better human beings
and better students well get to that in
one second first I want to say thank you
to a new sponsor the tides of history
can go to the Apple podcast app or
wherever you listen to podcasts iTunes
SoundCloud Google tides of history it's
a brand new podcast it's really great
I've listened to a few episodes of it
it asks you why are there states
country's taxes Wars and it traces the
history of all of the institutions under
which we currently live all the way back
to the 13th and 14th centuries he takes
on time periods from the fall of Rome
and the rise of the early modern Empire
he talks about the roots of the modern
world
how did capitalism start how did global
trade start right all the questions all
of the main concepts that underlie shows
like mine begin with shows like tides of
history what are the roots of all the
things that we discuss here on the show
one of the roots of the American
Founding tradition one of the roots of
the left all of these things can be
found hundreds and hundreds of years ago
history is not just a blank slate every
time somebody is born history pre-exists
you and it has an impact on you and it
has an impact on the civilization in
which you live that's what tides of
history is there to teach this could be
really dry stuff it isn't it's really
entertaining it's a really good listen
it this all talks about the period of
time during the Renaissance just before
the Enlightenment which is a really kind
of under-examined period of history we
all like to look at enlightenment
philosophers we all like to look at at
the some people like to look at the dark
ages and the so-called dark ages of the
Roman Empire but the period of time
that's most ignored is the Renaissance
and that really was the birthplace of
modern civilization go listen to the
first episode of tides of history on
Apple podcast or wherever you listen to
podcast or Google tides of history to
find the podcast today it really is an
excellent podcast I highly recommend it
so go check it out okay so back to this
back to this story so this coach Kennedy
kneels on the 50-yard line and the court
has decided that he's a public employee
which as I say is Maine that may be
arguable and he's a public employee was
he a public employee who was acting
under private auspices or was he a
public employee who was doing basically
preaching and so here's what the courts
and even if he was doing preaching was
it violating his job description like if
I if I go into a classroom and I say
listen the judeo-christian value system
is the best value system and it
generates better human beings is that
preaching or is that teaching now I
would suggest that living in Western
civilization that is based on
judeo-christian tradition that would
actually be teaching not preaching I'm
not saying you have to believe in the
Bible I'm not saying you have to believe
that God gave the Ten Commandments on
Mount Sinai I am saying that those
beliefs were the foundation stone of
Western civilization which is true okay
so judge Millan G Smith wrote this in
concurrence and this is the crux of the
matter he writes the context
bolster the perception that the district
was endorsing religion here it is okay
here's the key point
irrespective of the district's views on
that matter a reasonable observer would
conclude in light of the history and
context surrounding Kennedy's conduct
that the district in actuality favors
religion and prefers Christianity in
particular hey listen teachers don't
have the absolute right to do and say as
what they want as employees of school
districts did they have the right to
fire this guy maybe but to suggest they
have an obligation to fire him that's
what the court is now saying not just
that they did the right but they had the
obligation because no public school
teacher can pray on the 50-yard line
without imposing his religious views on
others let's make something absolutely
clear that is an imposition of a
religious you on others that ruling is
an imposition of a secular religious
view on others it is the imposition of
the idea that religion must be
disfavored but the First Amendment must
be applied in Reverse
that freedom of religion is not to be
protected that instead we have to
disestablish forcibly disestablished
anybody's religious belief no matter
whether they're forcing it on anybody or
not again this isn't even the equivalent
of the guy going into the classroom and
preaching this is the equivalent of him
doing something people are free to show
up or not show up it's voluntary for the
left the presence of religion itself is
insulting so how does this tie in with
the broader argument about children
here's what the left is seeking to do
they're seeking to say that if a
five-year-old can be taught by their
teacher without parental permission that
he is a she but a 15 year old cannot
have the option of praying at the
50-yard line with a coach that's an
agenda folks okay that's not about
protecting the innocence of children
it's about depriving them of certain
types of choice that they don't like and
giving them types of choice that they do
like when I say types of choice I mean
screwing them up permanently in many
cases because it is important to
promulgate a leftist view of social
politics that's scary stuff and you know
that's that's got to be fought at every
turn bye-bye good good will people who
are parents okay I'm a parent you try to
do this to my kid you try to do this to
my kid you wonder why people are taking
their kid out of public school and
sending them to private school you
wonder why people are retreating from
the public square you wonder why the
fever-pitch from politics is so high
right now it's because of garbage like
this people feel that their children are
being threatened by outsiders who think
that they
how to raise their children better than
I do you don't even know my kids names
you don't know their birthdays you don't
know a damn thing about them you don't
care about them there's a point that
Phil Gramm made at one point there was
some some lefty that he was he was
interviewing on a Senate committee and
the senator was questioning the the it's
leftist and left I said I care about
your children as much as you do and Phil
Gramm said what are their names
that's exactly right parents have the
ability to raise their children and not
only the ability the duty you have the
duty to raise your child and you have
the duty to raise your child under a
rubric of values that makes them a
better human being that is your charge
in this life for our society to ignore
that and fight actively against it is a
true evil and what we're looking at
right now is a serious battle against
truth and decency just horrifying okay
so in other news and the more political
front there's a new poll out president
Trump has been spending the last few
days ripping on Senate Republicans he
went on Twitter this morning again
ripped on Senator McConnell ripped on
bob corker the senator from Tennessee
and I understand him ripping on
McConnell he doesn't feel like
McConnell's doing the job ripping on bob
corker it's kind of weird since he
actually interviewed bob corker for his
Secretary of State it seems more like
Trump is angry at these people than like
he is actually interested in changing
their behavior except as regards to him
this is a distinction you know if you're
going to attack senators the purpose of
attacking a senator presumably is to
move him on the issues and can leverage
senators but I think that right now
Trump is sort of lashing out at senators
because he doesn't like them personally
so you know at the in that rally on
Tuesday that president Trump did in
Phoenix he attacked both of the senators
from Arizona McCain and flake he attacks
McCain because McCain didn't vote for
the Obamacare appeal that seems fair to
me he attacked flake because flake was
mean to him you know that seems to me
less productive right now there's a
serious possibility that Republicans
lose flake seat if flake were to lose
the primaries if flake loses the
primaries right now I am better shot
that flake wins the general then Kelly
Ward who's his primary opponent he'll
award maybe great I don't know that much
about her but the fact is that when
you're talking about primary people not
because you want to change in their vote
but because they're mean to you
this is not positive stuff the polls
show that that people disapprove of
Trump's behavior largely for all the
talk about Trump propping up Republicans
in 2016 it was really the other way
around Trump on
performed every single Republican Senate
candidate throughout the country except
perhaps from the I think there was a
Senate race in Ohio where he over
performed but that was a rarity the vast
majority of cases Trump underperformed
the Republican Senate candidate so
there's really Republicans who dragged
Trump across the finish line not the
other way around and right now there's
the possibility that if Trump doesn't
get his act together he could drag down
a few Senate candidates it's almost
impossible for Republicans to lose the
Senate this time around that's just the
way that it works
remember senators are elected once every
six years and we rotate so only a third
of the Senate is up every two years this
two-year cycle is very very bad for
Democrats but Trump's activities could
hurt Republicans there's a new George
Washington University battleground poll
trying to get a sense of how Americans
feel about Trump's behavior and it's it
ain't good okay basically asked if they
agree or disagree with the statement
that Trump's behavior is not what I
expect from a president 71% agreed only
27 percent disagreed 68 percent people
said they were worried that Trump's
words and actions could get us
accidentally involved in an
international conflict just 29 percent
disagreed do these polls really matter
very much
they only matter if something goes wrong
if people are already predisposed to
blenheim Trump if something goes wrong
what happens when something goes wrong I
think that's what we're being set up for
this weekend by the way I think that we
are being set up for this weekend
there's a big hurricane scheduled to hit
Texas and the media are all over the the
media are all over this thing
the media are very much focused on
what's happening in this hurricane in
Texas and they will see how bad the
hurricane is but if there is some sort
of disaster and Trump is not immediately
Ani I promise you they're looking for
another Hurricane Katrina situation and
they know that the public is predisposed
to think that Trump is chaotic and
doesn't know how to govern it so Trump
better do a great job with it
Trump is at 34 35 percent approval
rating right now he has not experienced
any serious crisis like zero serious
crises so if there is a crisis and he
Boches it then you could see him tank
and that really could hurt Republicans
meanwhile there's chaos inside his own
administration I don't like this very
much Gary Cohen who is president Trump's
top economic adviser he said quote the
administration can and must do better
and consistently and unequivocally can
unequivocally condemning groups like
white supremacist groups and do
everything we can to heal the deep
divisions that exist in our communities
he said he felt compelled to quote voice
my distress over the events of the past
two weeks he said he was disgusted in
Nepal's with Trump's response to white
nationalists role in the violence
Charlottesville I agree with a lot of
this by the way but Gary you worked for
the guy you work for the guy like
shouldn't you say that to him he'd say I
understand you're in a difficult
situation when you work for Trump
because if you feel like you're doing a
good job you don't want to give up the
power to help the American people but
you still are working for Trump you know
somebody at the company had a severe
disagreement with me publicly it would
be a problem and it is a problem for
Trump when people inside his own
administration are ripping him publicly
and openly get like Gary cone is we'll
talk more about that plus I do want to
talk about the Democrats new attempt to
cast Trump as a crazy man and we'll get
to the mailbag but first we're gonna
have to go over and subscribe for $9.99
a month you've got a subscription to
daily wire and if you subscribe right
now be part of today's mailbag we are
going to do a fulsome mailbag today to
make sure that you subscribe $9.99 a
month you get the rest of the show live
on other weekdays other than Friday you
get Michael Knowles's show live you get
Andrew clavin's show live both great
shows and right now if you subscribed at
the annual subscription you get this the
finest of all possible vessels the
leftist tears hot or cold tumblr it is
the greatest thing that you will ever
see in your entire life once you hold it
in your hands you'll understand the both
the weight and the gravitas of this
particular piece of kitchen item of
kitchenware so check that out
$99 a year plus if you want to just
listen to us later go over to SoundCloud
or iTunes and subscribe leave a sort of
view we always appreciate it helps us in
our rankings on iTunes make sure you do
that we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so I agree with a lot of what Gary Cohen
is saying about Trump's response to
Charlotte's well but I don't work for
Trump
I understand Trump making a move against
Gary cone now if you were going to do so
and I do wonder if Gary Cohen is setting
himself up for that I wonder if Gary
Cohen is Trump's economic adviser he's
setting himself up so that when Trump
fires him he can say that Trump fired
him for insubordination on an issue
where Trump was wrong rather than firing
him for being a globalist right which is
sort of what Breitbart wants him to be
fired for but there is this burgeoning
attempt by people on the left and some
people on the on the right to cast Trump
as a crazy person a Democratic
congresswoman yesterday suggested that
there are signs that worried us about
Trump's mental health this is Zoe
Lofgren of California comparing Trump to
a person who has Alzheimer's actually
the legislation urges the Vice President
along with the cabinet to secure the
assistance of medical professionals as
has been noted by your prelim into this
a lot of people are concerned about the
president's behavior he seems to lack
impulse control he swings from topic to
topic any of us who's had an older
person that we know suffering from a
mental decline can see certain signs
that worry us okay so this kind of
nonsense you're not supposed to say this
stuff publicly generally because I mean
this was what they called the Goldwater
rule that you're not supposed to
psychologically assess people that you
don't know very well I mean we used to
do it all the time with with Obama say
they had a narcissistic personality
disorder but that's not quite the same
thing as saying the president is legit
crazy like Obama was clearly a
narcissist but that doesn't mean he
can't do his job Trump I think also is a
narcissist I think that he fits the
textbook definition of a narcissist but
that does not mean that he's not capable
of doing his job this is all building up
so that if Trump does something wrong
everybody's ready to pounce this is all
of a setup the punchline is coming okay
there's all this out the punchline is
Kevin plus I'm sorry Democrats can't
talk about crazy old people if they're
not gonna mention Nancy Pelosi here's
the the minority leader in the house
talking about free speech see if you can
see what she's saying that is wrong and
stupid could the Park Service justify
denying that organization their free
speech right
because the Constitution does not say
that a person can shout yell wolf in a
crowded theater if you are endangering
people then you're you don't have a
constitutional right to do that okay so
she's wrong on the law and also why
would you shout wolf in a crowded
theater it's a weird thing to shout they
shouting elephant in a crowded theater
and she means fire in a crowded theater
but she's a dummy
so she says wolf in a crowded theater um
yeah if we're gonna talk crazy town's
then then crazy Nancy Pelosi should be
at the top of that list Democrats really
don't get to go down this path okay time
for some things I like things I hate
then we'll do a fulsome mailbag so
things I like this week we've been doing
things associated with blindness because
of the Eclipse this is actually a very
serious movie about blindness this is a
it's a terrific film The Miracle Worker
the Academy Award winners Anne Bancroft
and Patty Duke and Bancroft plays Helen
Keller teacher Patty Duke plays Helen
Keller and this is one of the this is
sort of the climactic scene of the movie
the the scene in which Helen Keller
realizes that words are associated with
with objects because she's basically
grown up unable to speak unable to
communicate properly and she's
frustrated about it inheres and Bancroft
as her teacher teaching her what water
is
it has a name
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean it is an amazing story the story
of coming home is truly incredible I
mean though the woman was blind and deaf
and couldn't speak and somehow they
figure she actually would give speeches
I mean by the end of her life she was
giving for many years she gave speeches
on college campuses okay litter imagine
trying to learn how to speak if you
can't see somebody's mouth move and you
can't hear what they're saying I mean
it's an unbelievable thing in the movie
The Miracle Worker is a classic this
young Anne Bancroft
people remember Anne Bancroft from
graduate which is a garbage movie but
this is an actual good movie The Miracle
Worker with Anne Bancroft and Patty Duke
and Mathis don't give me that look the
graduates garbage we'll talk about that
another time maybe we'll do a
deconstructing the culture on why
Malthus is wrong about about that
particular movie okay so other things I
like in 10 there's a baseball brawl I
have to show it that's just the way it
works so there's a baseball brawl
yesterday between the Tigers and the
Yankees then the funny thing about
baseball brawls is basically the way
they work is one person gets in a punch
and then everybody just tackles each
other and then they just dance around so
that's what this baseball brawl looked
like so Cabrera now will Olek out
there's a fight at home plate miguel
cabrera going toe-to-toe with Romo and
they're swinging with him 'ok yes they
were
Wow
what is the landlady this is a very
funny oh they're still there when
she talked about how because during one
of these brawls like everybody cleared
to see bullpen coming in people running
and he says that in one of these brawls
he and a guy from the opposite team were
friends and snowed actually just like
fake punch each other they like dance
around they fake punch it look like they
are really clock each other but that's
what baseball brawl is always remind me
of that the number of great baseball
brawls is really low yeah there was it
there's one last year where there is I
think was between Texas and Blue Jays
where where the second baseman threw a
punch that was like a first class it was
a first class cross but mostly these
baseball fights are not very good okay
time for a quick thing I hate and then I
want to get some mailbag okay so the
thing that I hate today one of the
things that really annoys me is how
there's a double standard with regard to
the sorts of racist jokes that people
make so there's this game of thrones
parody that is not very good that was
pushed by huffington post a woman in
karolina moreno wrote about this this
game of thrones parody called gente of
thrones says this once no knows
something so what is it it's a bunch of
it the the idea is that all of the
kingdoms have to get together to stop
the White Walkers okay this is supposed
to be in Manhattan so that what are the
White Walkers this is the very end of
the parody what are the White Walkers of
course who do they have to get together
to stop you'll see
it's the perfect place fix up I can't
wait to try one of those chopped cheese
everybody's been talking about
[Music]
it shows a bunch of Hispanic people
Dominican Republic and Puerto Ricans
saying we have to get together and then
they go up to the the north of New York
and who's coming in is a bunch of
hipsters carrying coffees gentrifying in
place oh god they have to be stopped
it's so terrible the white walkers okay
now we can all kind of laugh at that I
guess but can you imagine if the
situation were reversed
imagine if for example there are a bunch
of people who made a parody video game
of Thrones about building a wall to keep
out the White Walkers and it turned out
it was a bunch of illegal immigrants
from Mexico can you imagine the number
of racist accusations that would appear
and it would likely be partially right
okay this is racist when you say that a
bunch of urban hipsters are white
walkers who must be prevented from
entering Manhattan because they're
ruining the city listen
New York's garbage anyway okay let's be
real about this there are parts of New
York that are ok but New York City lie
I'm sorry for people who live there like
it's a fun place to visit my sister has
lived there for a while but like if
you're coming in and gentrifying crappy
areas of the city like half the city
used to look like escape from New York
so if you're coming in and gentrifying
and building a coffee house I really
don't think you've done anything deeply
wrong ok
I don't get to the mail bag so let's
just do that now Matt says do you think
a black kid from the inner city has a
greater than average chance of getting
accepted to college because of
affirmative action or a less than
average chance because they graduated
from a crappy school so the answer is
that they have a greater than average
chance of being accepted to college but
they have a less than average chance of
graduating from high school with the
proper grades okay that's just the
statistical facts if you graduate from
high school with the same grades as a
kid who isn't like we don't want to
compare apples and oranges it is a
complex social phenomenon schools in the
inner city are not very good parenting
in the inner city is largely not as good
as parenting in the suburbs and that's
not just because of the quality that's
not because of the quality of people per
se it's because of the qualities of the
decisions made by parents if you're a
single mom it's gonna be very hard for
you to provide the same sort of
environment learning environment you
know in a crime-ridden area that it is
for a two-parent household in the
suburbs to provide that environment for
a kid that's not a racial thing that's
nothing with black and white a black
two-parent family and the suburbs is
gonna be better off than a single mom in
the inner city but it means that kids
tend to underperform in the inner-city
academically which is why when you
a lot of those kids moved to charter
schools outside those neighborhoods they
suddenly perform really well this is why
we shouldn't lock kids down to the
public school in their neighborhood we
should allow them freedom of choice to
go to schools outside their neighborhood
then there's the question of affirmative
action affirmative action is constructed
in order to make it easier for black
kids from the inner city to get into
school I mean that's what it's
constructed to do so of course it's
easier by that standard hey Daniel says
hello Ben will you ever grow a beard and
is taxation theft so two weird questions
will I grow a beard so there I've I've
grown some pretty heavy stubble it
starts to itch I guess there's certain
point it's really itchy so I'm not
really huge on the growing of the beard
also I mean look at this Poonam you want
to hide that behind a beard unless
they're an internal girl like a tormund
Giantsbane style like heavy beard and
just looked like I was gonna crack
someone's skull all the time then maybe
that seems like a lot of work and a lot
of grooming and food gets caught in it
so I'm not so big on it is taxation
theft so my view on taxation is as I say
as I've said before read Richard
Epstein's book takings basically
taxation is theft unless you're getting
back the amount of services that justify
the taxation and it has to be you
getting back the amount of services not
society at large you so if you are taxed
for the Defense Department it is the
purpose of tax not the amount of tax
that's really at issue so the purpose of
taxation finally tax you because there's
an imminent nuclear assault on the
United States and we need to build up
our defense cap capabilities
you're getting back the benefit right
you are being taxed for a collective
benefit of which you receive if you tax
me for welfare I'm not receiving the
welfare so you're just taking my money
and giving it to someone else then
taxation is theft its redistribution
Haley says do you think one should go to
college for degree they don't currently
need is it worthwhile to have a degree
just in case thanks well depends on the
degree I mean I think that your your
degree should always be focused toward
job prospects I think that you know if
you want to go get a degree in Western
Civ go for it but that doesn't
necessarily come along with a job offer
i I think that it is very important that
people be educated and be ready to work
even if they are not currently doing so
so even before I was married I always
wanted to marry someone who had the
capacity to get a good-paying job
specifically because I think that it's
important if god forbid something should
happen to me that my wife be able to
take care of her
I think that's that's a decent decent
measure of getting an education but you
shouldn't get a degree if you're better
off not getting a degree if you're
better off moving to Nebraska and
working on a pipeline then do that it's
all about jobs daniel says what do you
think is the biggest obstacle standing
in the way of a libertarian republican
merger so it used to be a social
conservative view of what government
ought to do it is not anymore then now
the biggest obstacle is the basic
Republican idea that government should
be involved in a ton of crap okay the
government should be involved in fixing
the world I don't think government
should be involved in fixing the world
libertarians are right about that on the
other hand as I say I think libertarians
look at Republicans and conservatives
and they say you people with your crazy
churches and your crazy God why can't
you just read I in Rand and the reality
is that without that that church based
social fabric without that
judeo-christian value based social
fabric you can't have a libertarian
society it quickly devolves into into
nihilism it quickly devolves until the
libertarianism will devolve into
libertine ISM without us being able to
restrain ourselves right this is John
Adams entire point he can't have a free
country without a moral and religious
people channeland says hello I would
like to answer my question you read last
week I mean so I remember I read a very
bizarre question last week about puppies
kitties piglets and baby sea turtles
what do they have in common I said
they're all animals well apparently the
correct answer was they they make people
if somebody said they make people happy
no that's a stupid answer Williams says
all of these mentioned babies are
protected by law but human babies are
not so that was that that is a that is a
better answer but not even it's really
not a true answer I mean the fact is
that once a baby is born its protected
by law I don't know that unborn baby sea
turtles are protected by law although
they may be they may very well be Travis
says some will say that God has
established morality in our hearts and
why do some of us have different or bad
morals and if it is based on belief then
why do we not have an epidemic of crime
among atheists I believe that morals
come from parents and other adults
during young age and not from the
existence or belief in God or religion
well okay so two things one that is
begging a question when you say that
morals come from your parents and that
your parents and society teach you about
morals I agree where do they get them
where do they come from you just said
they don't come from from the human
heart
so don't your parents have the human
heart where did their standards come
from I mean at some point to work humans
on planet earth where do they get their
morals so you can't have it both ways
you can't say that nature doesn't
generate morality but your parents
generate morality without revelation
doesn't work that way if you want to
make the natural law case that human
marette that morality springs up in
human hearts you can do that
and you can then say Revelation is less
important but if you're gonna deny
nature and natural morality then it's
very difficult to deny revelation as the
source of morality so that is that
that's my answer on that you know as far
as why do we not have an epidemic of
crime among atheists because atheists
were raised in a judeo-christian value
system and still believed in the
fundamentals of that value system even
if they don't believe in the God that
provided them as far as natural law and
the idea that the human mind reflects
God's mind on morality
I think obviously there are certain
basic things that most human societies
have in common like don't murder right I
think that the Judaic take on what are
the things that I actually mentioned
this earlier in the show without even
reading this letter the basic takes on
things like don't kill people that I
think is pretty well embedded in the in
the human code but don't kill people
versus war is an interesting distinction
because a lot of societies have
discovered don't kill people but there
are also very few societies that have
discovered that don't kill people
applies to everyone right everyone who's
not actively attacking you Isaac says hi
Ben I'm uncertain of my stance on law
enforcement what are your thoughts on
balancing the power of law enforcement
and the protection of civil rights could
all problems be solved simply by getting
rid of bad laws for example the war on
drugs could privatization play a role so
I think that you should not put a law in
the books unless you want it enforced I
think that law enforcement is there to
protect your rights if they're not
protecting their rights and they've
obviously exceeded their their mandate
drew says then why is it the larger
cities in history are typically the most
evil blatantly sinful Nineveh Sodom
Gomorrah Rome Las Vegas New York thanks
for what you do drew I wouldn't exactly
compare Sodom and Gomorrah to New York
Las Vegas is a better argument but I
think the answer is that when you stack
a lot of people in a very small amount
of space then there's a lot of conflicts
that inherently rises up and there's two
ways of dealing with the conflicts one
is with tyranny and the others the
others with libertinism when you have
people who are separated and they're and
they're in family units and there's not
a lot of people right around them you
to focus in on how do you make your
family good right and there's less
friction from the people right around
you but think of living an apartment
like I live in a house now but we lived
in a condo for a while there's obviously
more conflict with the person on the
other side of the wall in the condo then
there is what the person on the other
side of my wall on my house there's more
separation that conflict means we have
to come up with a basic agreement that
agreements either going to be that we
abide by a certain set of rules together
or and that can very quickly devolve
into tyranny because we all want to
control each other's behavior or it
can't evolve into you do whatever you
want on your side of the wall I'll do
whatever I want on my side of the wall
never the twain shall meet but then when
you piss me off I'll kill you right
there then and very often that's how it
ends in big cities people aren't people
as much as we'd like to talk about
people need other people we do but too
much of other people will make you crazy
michael says what does ben shapiro have
to stop himself from buying if he finds
himself with some extra cash or do you
just stock pallet like Scrooge McDuck
and swim in it with the leftist tears
mug in hand so I do in fact have a
Scrooge McDuck money bin I need to enjoy
swimming around in it and just bathing
in my cash my rules of cash but what do
I have to stop myself from buying so I
don't I mean books typically but I don't
stop myself from buying books because
it's part of my ongoing quest to learn
things I buy lots and lots of books I
have piles of books around my house I
have a pile right next to my bed drives
my wife insane
I've got a pile of books next to my bed
that's gotta be 40 books high and I'm
gradually going through it and then you
know there's that meme have you seen
that meme of the guy who's walking with
the girl and then he turns around and
looks at the other girl right this is
the this is this meme that's going
around online now very famous so I
thought that the best version of that
was guy walking next to the girl and the
girls his girlfriend and the girlfriend
was book on my bedside stand and then
the one who he's checking out his new
book that just came out and that's sort
of my problem is that I have a bunch of
books that I have to read and been
sitting there for months and then I see
a new book that came out and I want to
read it so books is the big one the
other thing is at some point I wanted
buy myself a really nice violin my
violin is not very good my violin is
like I got it from my grandfather it's
probably worth maybe six or seven grand
but a really nice violin costs a minimum
of 25 grand probably and so I am
definitely stocking up for that
emmanuel says do you think Republicans
will ever win statewide elected office
in California again are we doomed to
sing further and further into the abyss
of the left the answer is yes I do think
that Republicans will win again through
one of two things one things get so bad
that Republicans
just the default position and people
react people wise up second all over the
leftists eventually leave California
after ruining the state Republicans
reoccupy the state in a hundred years
and it becomes read again right this is
my theory of population movement is that
Republicans come conservatives come make
a place awesome left his follow make the
place crap conservatives leave the place
devolves further into crap leftists
leave conservatives reoccupy and make it
good okay
now Karen says hey Ben my parents got a
pet hamster this weekend they named Tim
mr. Shapiro's and your honor I am deeply
honored do you think there's a chance
that Republicans completely abandoned
Trump so he can go to go on to create
his own political party and they can get
some things done in Washington thanks
for doing what you do well I don't think
that Republicans will abandon Trump I
think Trump may abandon Republicans I
think Trump may get so frustrated that
he decides screw you I'm forming my own
little coalition and he goes some people
on the left and some people in the
Republican Party and tries to get things
done the problem is the people who love
him from the Republican Party are not
even close to the people who are sort of
okay with him on the Left the people
okay with him on the Left like big
government the people who are okay with
him on the right are typically very much
in favor of his regulatory cuts for
example so there's not a lot of common
ground there okay so here are a couple
of live questions what is your favorite
Monty Python skit or movie so my
favorite Monty Python movie is Holy
Grail obviously that and my favorite
skit in that movie is still the duck
skit the witch in the duck skit well
Neal says would you consider being gay a
byproduct of free well from God in other
terms but we have gay people if religion
never existed and science was our only
foundation would it be considered
counterproductive to the species well I
mean I don't know that's a weird way to
put it I would suggest that all sexual
activity has a voluntary component I
don't know that all sexual drive has a
voluntary component your temptation is
your temptation I think there are
environmental impact on your temptation
I mean every study ever done has
suggested this but I think that the
notion that it is pure science that if
it weren't for if it weren't for our
capacity to choose would there be
homosexuality sure I mean bonobos have
have homosexuality so the idea that that
only heterosexuality can be found in
nature is not true what evolution select
against it yes evolution would clearly
select against it would remain a very
very small contingent
of the population okay Mitchell says
then I've noticed our generation just
wants to fight to make everything fair
why do most young people think life is
going to be fair how do we convince them
it's never gonna be fair all we ever
hear is how we deserve and it's not fair
but both of these statements are stupid
no one deserves anything life will never
be fair Mitch I agree with you one of my
pet peeves is the idea that life is fair
it's because in America we want people
to have a fair shot but having a fair
shot does not mean fairness of outcome
and it's very easy to mix up the two we
tend to look at two people who have an
unequal outcome and then we say Society
must have screwed them that's not right
it's quite possible that they make
decisions in their life that were bad or
that they started from different places
in society didn't do anything to them
okay
Zachary say hey Beth says Haman as a
Christian who is exploring my faith I'm
interested in learning more about
Judaism how welcoming is the synagogue
to Christians well you can show up I
mean like no one's gonna throw you out
we don't do conversions so the it's
difficult to convert to Judaism we
actually discourage conversions mainly
because you're taking on an enormous
number of Commandments that you actually
don't need to do to get into heaven but
if you're interested in learning about
Judaism there are a lot of books on it
the synagogue probably wouldn't be the
best place to start is the truth because
we mumble a lot to ourselves for two
hours basically that's what an Orthodox
service looks like there's some singing
but there's a lot of mumbling and so if
you're not ensconced in that then it
probably does not it's not like it's not
where you go for a great time this
synagogue but if you're looking to learn
about Judaism I would start with the Old
Testament read the Old Testament that's
amazing how many people who believe in
the Old Testament have a nephew read the
thing let's see someone says do you
watch Rick and Morty I don't even know
what Rick and Morty is so I will have to
check it out
Mathis is giving me a skeptical look
Mathis is my adopted son dictates that I
must actually check it out so I will now
check out Rick and Morty that has now
become an obligation upon me well we'll
find out how that goes okay so finally
we've reached the bottom of the mailbag
there are no more questions to be asked
this week but if you wish to subscribe
the next week you too can be part of the
mailbag and have all of your life
questions answered we'll be back here on
Monday try not to screw things up he did
ok last weekend it wasn't so bad last
weekend please try not to screw things
up so much this weekend I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]